♪ ♪ ♪
- Un seul débat entre les deux
finalistes à quatre jours
du vote. La jommmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmé
de Marine Le Pen, celui
qu'elle a privilégie pendant
cette campagne : la baisse
MARINE LE PEN, candidate à
l'élection présid. française
augmenté les taxes sur
le carburant que ça a décl
d'abord, des problèmes
de pouvoir d'achat pour
la crise des gilets jaunes.
EMMANUEL MACRON, candidat à
l'élection présid. française
tel que Mme Le Pen l'a décrit,
le bouclier.ucucucuclier,
ça consistait à bloquer les prix
de l'électricité et le gaz.cecee
que la baisse de la TVA.
Parce que vous avez voté
contre ce bouclier.
vous en dites beaucoup.
- Marine Le Pen arri
avec un fort désir de revanche.
Il y a cinq ans, sa performance
ce qu'elle avait elle-même
reconnue pare.e.e.e.e.
Emmanuel Macron avait remporté
la mise haut la main avec
lui a été souvent reprochée.
- Jusqoioioioioit aller la Frane
pour aider l'Ukraine?
Emmanuel Macron.
de 2022; un échange qui devait
ururururur la guerre en Ukraine
a vite débordé sur la relation
de Marine Le Pen avec
- Parce que vous dépent t t t te
vous dépendez de M. Poutine.
Parce que quelques mois après
avoir dit cela, rararararararart
en 2015, auprès d'une banque
russe, la First Czech Russian
Bank, proche du pouvoir.
- Je suis une femme abso
et totalement libre, et que
je défends parce que je suis
démontré toute ma vie.
- Vous avez propos
la plus grosse subvention
aux hydrocarbures.
climatiques, Emmanuel Macron
avait l'occaaqaqaqaqaqaquer
sa rivale, il l'a fait.
- Vous êtes climatosceptique!
le coup. Sa réponse était prête.
- Maisêêêêêêêtes un peu
climatohypocrite. D'ailleurs,
c'est peut-être pour ça que
à votre volonté de régler
rororororororoblèmes-là.
- La réforme des retetetetetetee
campagne, a fait l'objet
d'échanges très vifs.
Emmanuel Macron veut faire
passer l'âge as,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,se
Marine Le Pen soit au contraire
qu'on ramène le seuil à 60.
- La retraite à 65 ans, c'est
une injustice absolu
- Ces progrès, faut pouvoir
les financer. Et avant même
ces progrès, notre régimedédédé.
- Je suis pour l'interdiction
du voile dans l'espace public.
- Vous allez créer la guerre
civile si vous faites cela.Je ve
sincérité.
- Il fallait s'y attendre,
c'est la question du port
du voile qui a créé les plus
forts moments de tension
dans ce débat.
- Que la France, patrie des
lumières, patrie de l'universel,
serait le premier pays au monde
à interdire les signes religieux
dans l'espace public.
- Le débat entre les deux
aspirants au poste de président
de la France a mis en évidence
le caractère irréconciliable de
leur vision du monde, à l'image
de la division du pays entre la
France des villes et la France
des régions et des campagnes